フンザ訪ねてそうです
バイドばっかり
もう山へよ
あっ意見もなんかしようと思ったんですけど
歌じゃないぞ
ネタがあるんですよ
ねだるんですよ時間がないんです
商品紹介しようと思ったジュースも飲んぢゃんだしああ
を待ってくださいよ
ないんですよ
あるんですけど時間がないんですよ
あの今日のバイトはカラー
まあまあ柄が出てるんでそれまで待っててくださいねー
ザート切りいます
円周率
覚えてるだけってみます
いけませんナンボみたいですよ
3.14159に653-87ゲサン兄さんが首脳級という端と端下山田所
みんなパブロックた僕してますか
あの世界的に有名な方のパブロピカソ感なんですけどすごい禿様
絵を描けるのが増税で有名なんですけど
パブロピカソの本当の名前ってすごい長いんですよ
それもいろんな名前なんか
長いんですよ
ピカソの
親が名前を付ける時にやっぱ
こう幸せなことになって堀とジーっていう
幸せな子どもになってほしいということですごい名前
番う長い名前をつけたんですよ
その名前はすごい長いんですけど
僕は
覚えました
聞いてください
なの未来でいいますからね見てくださいよ
pablo ディエゴホセフランシスコとボール残念馬場前のクリスヴァンクリスピア
のドラスシトリン dat 類スイープ仮想
ああああああ